Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Brittlav und
Ja, Ausgabe Nummer vierundvierzig steht an und was hatten wir denn bisher? Corona, Corona, Corona, Corona, da war doch noch irgendwas anderes.
Ja genau, da ist auch noch dieser Brexit, der noch äh in der Luft hängt und nachdem's jetzt äh schon ein paar Monate her ist, nämlich im achtzehnten Juni haben wir das letzte Mal darüber gesprochen,
mal wieder ein Update an, denn es ist ja dann doch unterm Strich einiges passiert und größere Entscheidungen stehen bevor und ich sage erstmal hallo zu John.
Hallo mal wieder.
John John Worst, ja, wir quatschen jetzt das siebte Mal miteinander tatsächlich und äh ja, das wird irgendwann nochmal ein schönes Zeitdokument.
Ja, genau. Ähm aber wir erreichen in den nächsten paar Wochen vielleicht schon einige Entscheidungen. Vielleicht werden wir ein bisschen Klarheit haben.
Genau,
Fangen wir doch vielleicht mal äh damit an, einen kleinen Rückblick zu machen, was so grob seit Juni sich eigentlich getan hat. Im Wesentlichen stand ja auch äh das Vereinigte Königreich so im Schatten des Kowit und die Bekämpfung.
Die Auswirkung der Kohlerkrise dürften ja recht umfangreich gewesen sein.
Ja genau das stimmt und und zuerst gab's die gab's die Diskussion so im späten Frühling und im Sommer,
so weil Großbritannien so von von Kowit betroffen war, was sind dann die Auswirkungen auf dem Brexit Prozedere? Ähm und Großbritannien hatte bis Ende Juni die Option,
sogenannte ähm Brexit Hansition Peari, also die Übergangsperiode zu verlängern also das bedeutet,
zwei Jahre noch mehr Zeit für die Brexit-Verhandlungen zu gewinnen. Aber die britische Regierung, besonders Michael Gover, so der, der Minister, der hauptsächlich für Branxen verantwortlich ist,
hatte diese Option, um mal an alles zu verlängern.
Definitiv im Juni abgelehnt. Also das bedeutet, dass trotz aller Probleme mit Corona, so Großbritannien steuerte dann auf so eine neue Beziehung mit.
Der EU ab Ende zwanzig zwanzig, also das bedeutet, dass die Uhr tickt sehr stark äh seid äh Ende Juni und diese diese Entscheidung der der Briten.
Das war ja keine keine große Diskussion, ne? In äh in Großbritannien äh diese transischen Pyree zu verlängern und auch die Opposition hat sich nicht dafür hart äh stark gemacht.
Ja genau, weil also dieses Spruch so sein sehr sehr wichtig in Großbritannien sollte und Hauswahl ähm ähm das haben wir letztes Jahr Geld Brexit dann, also Großbritannien.
Will dieses Themenfeld nicht mehr debattieren, also Brexit ist irgendwie irgendwie vorbei obwohl wir wir natürlich wissen, also wenn in den praktischen Auswirkungen ist es überhaupt nicht vorbei
Aber es gibt ja Druck, also wir brauchen ja Entscheidungen und und wir brauchen so Fortschritte. Es geht mehr um.
Irgendein Brexit durchzuführen, auch seine Gute. Äh also das ist das ist Punkt eins, aber der zweite Punkt vielleicht noch wichtiger. Es gab ja nicht so einen Deal, parteiintern bei den Konservativen vor der Unterhauswahl letztes Jahr.
Eigentlich es gibt die so Brexit-Radikalen, die wollten so raus ohne Deal und Boris Johnson war ein bisschen Antik pragmatischer, so. Er wollte zumindest einen Deal haben. Außerdem.
Die Einigung zwischen diese beiden Gruppen in der Konservativen war, okay,
Wir wir schließen einen Deal mit Brüssel ab, so so dieses Deal von von November zwanzig neunzehn. Aber nur unter den Umständen, dass die diese Übergangsperiode wird nicht.
Verlängert. Also das war so ein parteiinternes Kompromiss bei den Grundservativen. Und das wird dann ein Grund, warum dann nicht gab, keine große Debatte im Sommer dieses Jahr, in Großbritannien, diese diese Verlängerung, diese Übergangsperiode nochmals zu verlängern.
Das war meine meiner Meinung nach eine eine verrückte Entscheidung wegen zumindest wegen Korona, äh aber so war es halt, also es gab in den letzten Monaten,
faktisch keine Debatte, war das die richtige Entscheidung, wo denn ich da so die brittene Autodipie,
die britische Politiker haben das einfach akzeptiert und um die die schlechten Auswirkungen von dieser diese Entscheidung ähm.
Haben die die diese Auswirkung möchte ich stammen? Bin ich nicht sicher. Aber so war's halt. Brexit bis dem einunddreißigsten Dezember zwanzig äh zwanzig zwanzig,
alles muss geregelt sein wird bis Ende des Jahres.
Hatte die Öffentlichkeit das auch so mitgetragen, so ohne Weiteres.
Ja, nicht so wirklich, also besonders weil weil Korona hat alles so so so dominiert. Also Brexit war sehr selten.
So auf zumindest.
In in den Nachrichten auf die erste Seite oder oder dem ersten so wichtigsten Ding. Ähm es gab ja ab und zu,
ähm ähm berichte darüber, aber es ging auch selbst nicht um die Parteiinterne Schwierigkeiten für Johnson, nicht um die praktischen Auswirkungen auf,
britische Wirtschaft oder oder dass die Großbritannien nicht für den Austritt noch nicht vorbereitet ist,
Also vielleicht wird das ja ein bisschen anders sein in den kommenden Wochen, aber in den in den letzten Monaten muss ich mal sagen, Großbritannien war in Sachen Brexit.
Für mich zu entspannt, alles war zu ruhig, also niemand hat die dieses Themenfeld aus meiner Sicht ernst genug genommen.
Gab's denn würdest du denn sagen, dass es so eine mehrheitliche Erwartung gab, dass es schon irgendeinen Deal geben wird?
Ja, also da sahen wir diversen Tendenzen in den in den letzten paar Monaten. Also grob.
In den Sommermonaten viele Leute Investments haben so gedacht, ja es ist nur eine Frage der Zeit, also Boris muss auf jeden Fall kompromissbereit sein.
Wegen die wirtschaftlichen Auswirkungen des von von Coved, also das bedeutet wirtschaftlich ist es in den Interessen von Großbritannien des Großbritanniens müssen so einen Deal abschließen.
Dann kamen wir mal am achten ähm September diese sogenannten Interno Market Bill in den in den in den ähm Housekommens.
Raus. Äh sogenannte britisches Binnenmarktgesetz. Und da kam dann die diese jetzt ähm.
Sehr bekannte Wörter von den Minister für Nordiland Brun Luris hat gesagt dieses Bill wird wohl Break international in a very spacifice and limited whey, also es ist.
Mit so internationales Recht, nicht nicht konform.
Und dann vor allem dann plötzlich dann Anfang September erschreckt, hey Moment mal, also was ist das denn? Also was bedeutet das das Großbritannien,
ist nicht bereit,
den Austrittsvertrag vom vom November zwanzig neunzehn zu respektieren, also wie könnte es so schnell so schief gehen? Also da redeten dann alle
von einem möglichen No Deal, also da im September waren alle dann sehr ähm äh sehr nervös.
Großel war stinkend sauer auf diesen Entwicklungen in Großbritannien.
Und hat sogar eine eine so eine juristische Prozedere gegen Großbritannien äh eingeleitet, hat den sogenannten Letriv Notefication nach Großbritannien geschickt, einfach mal das
Brüssel hat Angst, dass Großbritannien respektiert nicht den den Austrittsvertrag vor Ende zwanzig neunzehn.
Ähm also da lief alles dann im September schon sehr schlecht. Aber dann Großbritannien, die börtliche Regierung hat dann von diese diese
äh sich von diesen so sehr erschreckende Positionen, also ein bisschen zurückgerudelt. Also ne im Moment mal, das ist nur eine Notfalllösung, ist nicht allzu schlimm wie wie Brüssel alles so fürsteht
Also dann gab's dann mal wieder ein bisschen mehr Optimismus in den letzten sage ich paar Wochen,
dass Boris Johnson bereit wäre, doch noch einen Deal abzuschließen.
Ich bin nicht sicher. Also ich denke, dass dieser Optimismus war ein bisschen äh übertrieben äh in den letzten Wochen in Großbritannien,
außer ein paar verschiedene Gründen, aber das ist zum Gobel den jetzigen Stand, also,
Deal wäre äh vermöglichen im Sommer, im September, Hashtag ähm so viel Pessimismus. Und dann in den letzten paar Wochen mal wieder ein bisschen mehr Optimismus auch.
Diese interne Marketbilder, darum dreht es sich ja jetzt eigentlich im Wesentlichen. Jetzt sollten wir vielleicht mal kurz reinschauen, was das Ding eigentlich genau macht. Ja
dass also der Austrittsvertrag, den ja Boris Johnson mit der EU unterschrieben hat, ja, der beschlossen ist, der legt ja relativ klar fest
dass Nordirland im.
Verbund im wirtschaftlichen Verbund mit der Republik Irland verbleibt und das quasi eine neue Zollgrenze entsteht zwischen,
Nordirland und dem Rest äh also und Großbritannien sozusagen, den Rest von UK, sprich eine, eine, eine Warengrenze
in der Irish C. Was ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch aus logistischen Gründen irgendwie äh sinnvoll ist, aber wie auch die Grenze
zum EU-Festland, Dova Calé, Vogsdorn et cetera äh sind halt diese Häfen im ähm im Westen.
Englands und Westen Schottlands halt nicht besonders groß und nicht nicht auf so eine äh extreme Abfertigungskapazität ausgelegt.
Trotz alledem, das war sozusagen,
zugesagt und diese interne Marketsbill ist ja, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, so ein Gesetz mit na ja, äh muss man alles nicht so ernst nehmen, weil wenn wir das irgendwie anders sehen, dann können wir das auch anders machen.
Genau, also es gibt zwei Aspekten von dieser Internotmarke. Äh erstens ist,
Ja, also wenn wir dann einen Deal zu den zukünftigen Beziehungen mit Postel anschließen, also alles ist nicht so so,
super ernst, also grob, alles geht dann oden nicht weiter, so das ist zumindest die wie die Regierung, dass das beschreibt.
Weißt du, was am schlimmsten ist, ist, wenn es keinen Deal gibt, ja, zu den Zuggebühren bisher EU
dann erlaubt dieses Internet ähm ähm äh gibt dann Großbritannien viel Macht über die Beziehungen zwischen
Nordirland und Großbritannien und und dann, dass es respektiert damit nicht mehr,
zwanzig neunzehn, also die was in den von zwanzig neunzehn schon ist und schon abgeschlossen ist Vision Großbritannien und die EU muss weiterhin gelten
auch im Falle, dass es keinen zukünftigen Beziehungsdeal gibt bis Ende des Jahres. Und so was bedeutet was, was die beiden Seiten schon abgeschlossen haben, muss
noch gültig bleiben. Und das ist was, wo dann gefährlich ist mit diesen diesen Interviews. Marke Bilder, so ist es. Es zerstört, was Großbritannien und die EU schon abgeschlossen haben.
Uns es verstößt ja auch gegen das Karfreitagsabkommen den Friedensvertrag zwischen Nordirland und Irland.
Ja und und innerhalb von Großbritannien und so ist da herrschen dann auch Schwierigkeiten zwischen Lorden, Shotland und und Wayos, weil wie du gerade gesagt hast, viele von diesen Häfen sind in Schottland, um in Wales und dann
wer dann zuständig ist für diese zukünftigen Marktregelungen
Also das ist dann das nimmt dann Macht von Kader von Adambra und zentralisiere dann die Macht dann mal wieder in Westmünster. Sowas bedeutet es nicht nur in in Bellfast, dass Leute dann auf auf dieses Gesetz sauer sind
oder in Brüssel, sondern auch in Adam in Carde. Also das bedeutet, dass es ein Gesetz äh also warum haben die Konservativen,
sowas gemacht, weil die wollen die Kontrolle dann,
für sich dann behauen. Also auch das bedeutet, dass die wollen schon abgeschlossene Entscheidungen.
Posel nicht weiterhin respektieren müssen. Also es ist so eine Huviocaking Eatid Gesells Francis.
Ähm und das ist dann ein Grund, warum es dann so sehr kontrovers ist. Und für Großbritanniens ruft, ist es auch natürlich sehr schlecht
weil wenn Großbritannien bereit ist, zu sagen, hey, Moment mal so, wir haben einen Vertrag mit der EU äh vor zehn bis zehn Monaten abgeschlossen und das wollen wir jetzt nicht mehr respektieren. Wer wäre dann bereit, ein Handelsankommen mit Großbritannien abzuschließen
wenn Großbritannien so unzuverlässig schon war, gegenüber die EU, also wenn in Sachen Großbritannien Hufe in der Welt ist es auch sehr schlimm.
Ja insbesondere war ja der bisherige Ruf in der Welt, der ist, dass äh Großbritannien immer für Roule of Law eingetreten ist und das quasi auch ein Exportschlager ist.
Ja, es ist Großbritannien ist für Green of Low, wenn wenn Großbritannien entscheiden kann, was den Grule isst. Ja, also das ist das ist das ist, wie man das beschreiben könnte oder aus Sicht, Aussicht der Britische Regierung.
Ja. Ja und das ist äh natürlich jetzt auch eine äh interessante Debatte im.
Im Parlament das ja in Großbritannien aus zwei Kammern besteht, das sieht man ja auch immer nicht so richtig, es gibt halt House of Comments und es gibt es Haus, die House of Lords House of Lords ist so ein ja so ein super skurriler,
Teil, den man, glaube ich, außerhalb von Großbritannien kaum noch verstehen kann. Das sind halt alles ernannte Personen, die da, glaube ich, mehr oder weniger auf Lebenszeit äh drinsitzen
ja die jeweils von der Regierung glaube ich auch sogar bestimmt werden. Ist das so.
Ja und und und, aber es gibt zum einen ein Formel, damit damit Oppositionspolitiker auch äh nominiert werden können.
So das bedeutet, ich gebe und es gibt so die sogenannten Cross-Banches. Also das bedeutet dann so unabhängige Parlamentarier da drin ist und das bedeutet das, obwohl Boris Johnson eine Mehrheit in dem Unterhaus hat,
hat er keine klare Mehrheit in im obere Haus. Also das ist worauf dieses Spiel Spiele war jetzt jetzt geht,
zwischen den beiden Häusern in Sachen Brexit, also obwohl das britische Unterhaus schon im September dieser international Marke zugesagt hat.
Ähm eine Abstimmung am neunten November im Oberhaus, wo die mit einem Riesenmehrheit der Mehrheit von über zweihundert Stimmen.
Die die wichtigsten Teile so des Internet Market Buil.
Haben die da im Oberhaus dann abgelehnt. Und dazu gab's zwei ehemalige Parteichefs der der Konservativen, William Hayk
und Michael Howard und Michael Howd ist extra eine sehr starke Euroskeptica, also der, der war David Comerings Vorgänger als als Parteichef der Konservativen.
Diese beiden haben gegen der Linie von Boris Johnson gestimmt. Also das bedeutet, dass die haben, die haben so gesagt, es ist ja sehr wichtig für, dass Großbritannien respektiert, internationales Reicht,
und das ist dann, es ist dann eine Schande, der dieses Internat Interno Markt und das bedeutet, dass wir die Oberhaus, wir nehmen dieses Gesetz dann,
mittelfristig wenn wir dieses Gesetz ablehnen können, also dieses Votum am neunten November war nur zu den,
bestimmten Teilen, die dem gegen den Austrittsvertrag und den Protokoll stoßen, aber es war sehr sehr wichtig, also alle steuert jetzt in Großbritannien auf ein großes Konflikt zwischen Oberhausen, Unterhaut.
Das britische Oberhaus kann nur für eine bestimmte Zeit ein Gesetz blockieren,
Aber das bedeutet, äh und was Großbritannien zur Zeit nicht hat, ist ausreichend Zeit für die Brexit-Verhandlungen. Also, wenn Großbritannien hätte noch, sagen wir ein Jahr noch für die Brexit-Verhandlungen,
wäre dieses Ablehnung im im Oberhaus nicht sehr relevant. Weil das britische Unterhaus könnte dann nächstes Jahr einfach mal noch einmal abstimmen,
und hat dann das Markt ähm wegen den sogenannten Powerman Act. Sie ist gegen der Wille der Oberhaus durchzusetzen.
Aber das baut Zeit. Das baut normalerweise ein Jahr. Und Großbritannien, die hat jetzt nur sechs Wochen, um Klarheiten zu schaffen in,
weil die Uhrtech bis Ende des Jahres ein ein Brexit-Abkommen mit Brüssel abzuschließen
Also das bedeutet, dass wegen dieser sehr kurzen Zeit diese Ablehnung in dem Haus ablauft, ist dann sehr sehr wichtig, also im House of Lords hat dann an Bedeutung gewonnen, weil die Zeitfenster so kurz ist.
Also.
Es ist wirklich äh Hahnebücher und ich meine das was da interessant ist, dass dieses Haus of Lord halt in dem Sinne eigentlich überhaupt gar keine richtige Vetokraft hat, sondern üblicherweise ist das immer so ein, man nennt das, glaube ich, auch Pink Pong
dass äh sogenannte Emantman-Zeit vielleicht beschlossen werden, die dann vom Parlament äh übernommen werden oder eben auch nicht, aber so richtig faktisch eine eine richtige Sperre können sie nicht machen, aber nur diese Verzögerung, die sie einführen können. Die ist jetzt hier
quasi der einzige Hebel.
Aber diese Verzögerung ist jetzt sehr wichtig. Also in der Regel, die können nur Dingen so ausbremsen und teilweise ändern, ja? Ähm also Arbeit diesmal ist es sehr, sehr wichtig.
Was ist denn die Strategie der EU derzeit in diesem Verhandlungsspiel? Ich meine, Verhandlungen sind im Prinzip ja gescheitert und die letzte Deadline ist eigentlich ja auch schon abgelaufen. Also es sollte doch jetzt eigentlich Anfang November.
Ein Deal beschlossen sein, damit er überhaupt auch noch ratifiziert werden kann, weil das ist ja erforderlich, dass alle siebenundzwanzig Mitgliedsstaaten der EU so einen Deal auch absegnen.
So, auf der Brüste Seite ist alles sozusagen sehr ruhig. Und.
Sage ich mal aus zwei Gründen. Äh Brüssel oder oder und die Mitgliedsstaaten der EU.
Sinn deutlich besser vorbereitet als Großbritannien.
Und die wirtschaftlichen Auswirkungen eines No Deals auf der EU sind deutlich geringer als für ähm für Großbritannien.
Und zweitens, man weiß ja schon, dass es gibt ja noch ein bisschen Spielraum in Sachen Zeit.
Also obwohl Brust so gesagt hatte, es muss alles so stehen bis Ende Oktober in Brüssel herrscht seit ein paar Wochen, ja also wir haben noch ein bisschen Spielraum.
Aus meiner Sicht,
so viel Spielraum gibt es ja nicht. Also man muss, wenn es einen ja einen Deal geben wird. Es muss ja einen Deal geben bis Ende der Woche nächste Woche. Ja, so den
zwanzigsten November. Also das ist im absoluten Deadline. Also wenn wenn dann es keinen Deal gibt
da ist dann die Ratifizierung auf der EU-Seite Dampf sehr sehr schwierig. Ich meine man brauche nicht nur die Abstimmung der der Mitgliedsstaaten, sondern auch das Europäische Parlament und das letzte Plenum im europäischen Parlament
ist zwischen den vierzehnten und siebzehnten Dezember. Und niemand will so zusätzlichen ähm Plenarsitzungen oder so dann dann hognisieren. Also die Zeit ist noch nicht komplett.
Ausgelaufen. Aber man muss auch sagen, es gibt immer noch Riesenprobleme und und und.
Unterschiedlichen Positionen, zumindest in drei Themenfelder, ja, also Fischereipolitik, den sogenannten Level Playmiel, also das ist den.
Wettbewerbsregeln oder Wettbewerbsgleichheit und in Sachen Governance, also wie strukturiert man ein System, das wenn wenn eine Seite.
Nisch respektiert, was die schon gesagt haben. Wie, wie findet man das so eine juristische System, damit eine Seite die andere Seite so juristisch so begrenzen oder oder bestrafen kann.
Und natürlich, also diese diese dritte ähm ähm so ein System, um um.
Die beiden Seiten so, die juristisch begrenzen zu können, ist natürlich sehr wichtig, wegen den Internet Marketing Spellers. Und das bedeutet, dass,
wenn auf beiden Seiten ist es viel Vertrauen gebe, wäre diese Frage vielleicht nicht so wichtig, aber weil es ist gibt zwischen den beiden Seiten sozusagen überhaupt kein Vertrauen,
diese Sugovernins Frage ist dann nicht nur sehr wichtig, sondern sehr schwierig zu lösen. Ähm also das ist dann grob, den den jetzigen Stand, also.
Ja noch ein kleines bisschen Zeit, aber nur an sehr sehr kleines bisschen. Also es ist es muss ja sehr nervös sein.
Ja genau, ich meine äh gerade in dieser Auseinandersetzung um die Fischerei. Ich meine, was ein bisschen eine absurdes Thema ist, ne? Weil das ist so emotional aufgeladen. Das ist so äh in den ganzen Brexit-Diskussionen äh im Vorfeld auch der,
das Referendums war das ja so ein ganz großes Ding, ja? Wir müssen unseren Fisch wieder zurück haben tatsächlich wird halt, ich glaube ich
habe jetzt die Zahlen nicht genau im Kopf, aber ich glaube, so sechzig Prozent des Fischfangs in britischen Gewässern wird halt von anderen EU-Ländern äh durchgeführt,
und natürlich herrscht dann sozusagen so diese Grundstimmung mit, die nehmen uns unseren Fisch weg und den wollen wir ja irgendwie haben, äh würde es jetzt zu keiner Einigung kommen, dann könnten sie diesen Fisch zwar
wunderbar fangen
Wenn sie überhaupt die Kapazitäten dafür haben, die sie nicht haben und das, was sie dann sozusagen mehr äh fischen, noch äh können, müssen sie ja auch irgendwohin verkaufen, weil das äh geht ja dann nochmal normalerweise eh in die EU.
Ne? Auf der anderen Seite hast du Frankreich, die natürlich da gerade ein großes Interesse haben, weil die haben nämlich diese flotten,
äh ähm am am am Kanal Ufer quasi und äh nutzen das derzeit sehr extensiv und es würde natürlich in dem Moment, wo sie dort nicht mehr fischen dürfen, dann wiederum,
Ihrer Fischerei, Flotte entsprechend schaden. Also ist Macron an der Stelle so ein bisschen Hardcore. Ich habe so den Eindruck, die,
Holländer haben sich schon so ein bisschen arrangiert so, also die
sind irgendwie vorbereitet, vielleicht trübt man ähm Eindruck da auch. Und die anderen Länder haben nur so begrenzt, da wirklich ein Interesse. Da kommt zwar noch Norwegen mit rein, aber die sind ja nicht in der EU.
Ja und und man will ja so feitlich einen Deal machen auf dem Basis von wie es jedes Jahr verhandelt wird zwischen Norwegen und die EU. So, hier also,
da könnte man so ein Kompromiss finden. Es gibt ja zwischen dieser die zwei, sage ich so.
Inhaltliche Themenfelder, so Level Plank, viel und Fischereipolitik. Da könnte man ein ein Kompromiss finden. Großbritannien kriegt ein bisschen mehr in Sachen Fischereipolitik und Brüssel kriegt dann ein bisschen mehr in Sachen,
so die die Produktionsstandards oder Regelungen.
Damit Großbritannien dann keine äh.
Vorteilhafte Wettbewerbssituation in der Zukunft kriegt. Und so sagen wir mal, man produziere ein Auto in Großbritannien
und die Mitarbeiter kriegen deutlich weniger Lohn, die Ausstöße aus den Fabriken sind deutlich wirtschafts
mich sorry im Umwelt beim ähm beschädigend aus als als als heutzutage. Das bedeutet, dass sie reduziert die Kosten für eine Produktion in Großbritannien, so eine Art
Domping dank nie niedrige Standards in in Großbritannien. Und das will die EU natürlich nicht. Also da da es gibt ja
merken Grunde für ein Kompromiss hier so zwischen Fischerei, Politik und Level Plankfield.
Aus meiner Sicht Brüssel wäre bereit sowas abzuschließen. Das Problem ist politisch auf der Seite Großbritanniens,
weil Boris Johnson hat, wenn er sowas abschließt, hat er dann ein politisches Problem.
In Großbritannien. Also ich sehe immer noch die, die Probleme deutlich mehr auf die britische Seite aus auf die EU-Seite.
Ja vor allem was er sich jetzt auch ähm zunehmend breit macht ist so dieses äh diese Ungewissheit.
In der Wirtschaft. Ich meine, die äh britische Wirtschaft ist ohnehin jetzt natürlich schwer angeschlagen, natürlich wegen Corona, das gilt ja im Prinzip für alle und ich würde aber sogar meinen, in Großbritannien war's auch nochmal ein bisschen
schlimmer, weil das alles sehr ungeordnet äh vonstattengegangen ist. Das heißt, es gibt ohnehin schon ein ähm,
eine eine Wirtschaftsflaute des äh britische Pfund ist auch schon sehr unter Druck geraten, schon vorher durch äh den Brexit, das ist ja mittlerweile fast eins zu eins zum äh zum Euro. Ich
kann mich noch erinnern vor ein paar Jahren, als ich da gewohnt habe, da war das irgendwie äh eins vierzig oder so, also ganz andere Situation und vor allem, ich meine, wie will man denn jetzt als Wirtschaftsunternehmen planen
wenn man noch nicht mal weiß was in sechs Wochen, wo auch nochmal Wein,
dazwischen liegt für Gesetze gelten, welche Regeln überhaupt gelten, es gibt überhaupt gar keine Systeme, es gibt keine Software, es gibt nichts, die Softwareunternehmen sagen alle, ja, wir können auch überhaupt gar keine Software schreiben, weil es steht ja nirgendswo, was diese Software tun soll.
Und ähm das ist natürlich jetzt ähm eigentlich so eine Situation. Ich meine, wenn man da jetzt mal drüber nachdenkt, also angenommen Deutschland wüsste nicht, was in sechs.
Wochen. Die Wirtschaft für ein Verhältnis zum Rest der gesamten Welt hat, das ist doch einfach vollkommen unvorstellbar.
Genau, ja, aber man muss auch sagen, ist, es wird Riesenänderungen geben, auch im Falle des ein Deal abgestoßen wird, also wir,
wir wissen zumindest, nehmen wir den Beispiel, dass äh man produziere eine LKW in Großbritannien, ja.
Und man will am zweiten Januar dieses LKW nach Frankreich exportieren.
Wir wissen zumindest, dass dieses LKW noch exportiert werden kann, ja.
Aber wir wissen nicht, ob man Frankreich, ein Soll von zwanzig Prozent erheben muss oder nicht.
Das mache dann für ein französisches Unternehmen, der dann eine LKW kaufen will, ein Riesenunterschied. Kauft man den in den in Großbritannien produzierte LKW oder eine andere.
Und man weiß ja nicht, wie es da so aussehen wird. In, in, in sechs Wochen. Oder wenn man da eine.
Irgendwelchen Waren exportieren besonders an ähm äh essen, also ähm ähm so Fleisch zum Beispiel.
Eine bestimmte Hand, sondern der Prozentzahl der der Fleischexpoten müssen an der Grenze kontrolliert werden.
Und das bedeutet, dass dies die Systeme, um einfach mal, wenn ich als LKW-Fahrer,
eine ein LKW vorne Lahm aus den den valisischen Hügeln so nach Frankreich exportieren will.
Ich hocke immer noch nicht die Systeme, damit ich dann registrieren kann. Was habe ich hier so exportieren? Und das ist dann der Grund, warum Großbritannien versucht
zwei riesengroßen Truckparks bauen. Äh einzigen Manzen und der andere in Asche oder so, Heustätten,
in der Nähe von Dover. Ähm damit man dann so.
Weil es keinen Platz gibt, an den Häfen selbst. Man musse dann diese Waren dann kontrollieren
Und man brauche dafür dann riesen viel Platz. Also das bedeutet, dass Großbritannien unsere für England zumindest. Die haben das die ganze Planungsgesetze,
geändert, um dann diese Truck Parks
noch bauen zu können vor dem Austritt. Aber diese Truck Parks sind noch im Bau
aber die hatten dann ein Problem. Moment mal, das sind nicht nur die einzigen Häfen, die es gibt. Es gibt anderen Häfen, wie Holly Hand zum Beispiel, also das ist dann sehr wichtig für den
ähm ähm Warentransport zwischen Irland und Großbritannien.
Wo bau man dann so ein Trockpark für Hobbyhäld? Um Moment mal so die Planungsgesetze in Wales, wo Harony Head steht, die sind in in ähm in Cardiff abgestimmt, noch nicht mehr im London, also wegen dem britischen Develution aus der aus der Neunzig.
Also die die können keinen Platz finden für für einen so ein Truckpark
Also was bedeutet das alle Waren aus Irland? Müssen jetzt in Warrington in der Nähe von Manchester kontrolliert werden, also was ist über hundertfünfzig Kilometer von Holihead, also die wenn man transportiere, dann waren,
aus Irland
nach Wales. Man muss zuerst nach England fahren, um die ganze Warm durch total süße kontrollieren. Und dann wieder in Wales hinein. Also, ist ja verrückte See schlecht ausgedachte, kurzfristigere Lösungen.
Und diese Lösung gelten dann.
Auch im Falle, dass ein Deal abgeschlossen wird, weil Großbritannien verlässt den EU Binnenmarkt und die Zollunion. Also das bedeutet, dass.
Groß Großbritannien stehe jetzt, wo sie britische Wirtschaft besonders in in Sachen Waren ähm Austausch. Vor entweder.
Eine sehr schwierige Situation oder ein echt verrückte Situation an am am Ende des Jahres. Und das haben wir schon in einem vorherigen Podcast debattiert. Ja
auch wenn die durchschnittliche Wartezeit für einen LKW an der Hafen von Dova sich von zwei auf vier Minuten verdoppelt
erreiche man dann schon in die erste Woche einen riesen LKW Schlange im Lange von siebentausend LKWs auf der Autobahn. Also das bedeutet, dass
egal wie es jetzt ausgeht, Großbritannien kann dann KOs an den Häfen dann erwarten. Am am ersten Januar. Und.
Irgendwie.
Das hat die hat die britische Debatte fast gar nicht gar nicht betroffen bis jetzt. Also was die praktischen Auswirkungen dann sind,
Ähm also Engpässen in in die Lieferketten für britische Supermärkten wird's auf jeden Fall geben. Egal wie es jetzt ausgeht. Und ich glaube schon Engpässen wie ein Kohle, also es.
Es ist so vollkommen verantwortungslos, es ist kaum zu fassen.
Ich meine diese Auswirkungen, die jetzt kommen, die müssen ja auch teilweise schon da sein. Ich kann mir ja, ich habe kenne jetzt gerade keine aktuellen Zahlen, aber ich kann mir ja auch wohl nicht vorstellen, dass.
Dass irgendjemand bereit ist in das Land, irgendetwas zu investieren, wenn äh überhaupt nicht klar ist, äh was die kommenden Bedingungen sind, das sind die Investitionen nicht enorm eingebrochen.
Ja genau, obwohl man muss auch sagen, also das ist auch dann in dem Schatten von von Krone ja ähm.
Und es gab ja ein paar Entscheidungen in Großbritannien.
Die vielleicht die Tür zu anderen Ländern der Welt dann zum Teil offen halten. Also zum Beispiel ähm im Pot von Fahrrädern, also es gibt eine,
eine heftige Zoll wird erhoben auf auf Fahrräder aus China, bei der Import in der EU und Großbritannien ist so gesagt, diese Zoll,
heben wir auf. Ja, so das bedeutet, dass wir wollen mir mit China dann.
Mehr Handel mit China nach dem Brexit, zum Beispiel, also das bringt natürlich Vorteile und Nachteile für britische Produzenten von Fahrrädern wie Bronken zum Beispiel,
aber da gibt's so Möglichkeiten vielleicht für Großbritannien
wenn man Lösungen finden könnte mit anderen Ländern der Welt statt mit der EU. Aber natürlich, ja, so, also in Investments geben woanders hin wegen diese diese gerade herrschende Unsicherheit.
Schauen wir doch mal kurz auf diese viel beworbenen äh Trade Deals, die ja angeblich Day One äh sofort nachdem äh die äh UK ausgetreten ist, äh angeblich da gewesen sein sollten. So kam's ja nicht
Der einzige wirkliche Trade Deal, der tatsächlich äh unterzeichnet wurde, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist ein Abkommen mit Japan.
Mit der dann viel bejubelt wurde und so, hier gucke mal, geht doch alles, äh, alles kein Problem. Nur ist natürlich gerade sehr ironisch, dass ausgerechnet mit Japan ja nun einige Monate vorher
ein Japan EU die abgeschlossen werden konnte der ja im Prinzip Großbritannien,
noch sehr viel mehr Freiheiten gegeben hätte, beziehungsweise in diesem Jahr sogar auch noch gibt. Äh hier Handel zu betreiben und dieser neue Deal, der jetzt unterzeichnet wurde
Der hat ja dann so lustige Klauseln, dass,
Die Kontingente, die Handelskontingente, die dann genutzt werden können im Wesentlichen, die ungenutzten Handelskontingente der EU sind.
Ja genau, also es ist so, es ist so ein sogenannten Rollover Deal, also das bedeutet, man man nimmt, was man schon hat, dank der EU,
kopiert einen großen Teil davon und fügt das in einem britischen, ja, britischen Japan Deal ein. Also die Wirtschaft, also das,
das rettet, faktisch, was Großbritannien schon hart aus EU-Mitgliedsstaat. Und wenn man schaut in den kleinsten Details.
Japan, Japan hat sogar ein bisschen mehr gewonnen, also Großbritannien hat man muss jetzt mehr Expose aus Japan,
akzeptieren.
Großbritannien akzeptieren musste aus EU-Mitgliedsstaat. Also es ist nicht unbedingt wirtschaftlich, vorteilhaft für Großbritannien. Also Großbritannien hat eigentlich nur gerettet, was die vorher hatten. Also
Ja okay, es ist besser, natürlich besser als nichts, ähm aber das ist kein Risiken, das ist kein riesiges Vorteil.
Und natürlich ein gutes Freihandelsabkommen anzuschließen. Das braucht ja Zeit und Zeit ist was Großbritannien nicht hart. Also was.
Was geht es noch zu verhandeln in ein paar Monaten, also einfach mal zu sagen, okay, wir kopieren, was wir schon hatten mit der EU
und wir geben euch mehr oder weniger das Gleiche weiter. Also ähm äh es es gab keine andere Option. Ähm natürlich die Kommunikation über dieses Freihandelsabkommen in den britischen Medien war so betrieben. Ja, also es gab wir können den,
den Importpreisen von Soisors aus Japan reduzieren
Ja, im Moment war es so Großmetanien importiert kein Zeug, sowas aus aus Japan. Aber sie sind die Niederländer produziert, ja? Also das bedeutet also, äh es macht ja keine Änderungen, aber das das war ja typisch auch so, es gab diese diese Bilder von den.
Handelsministerin Trance, also mit denen japanische Handelsminister und ja das ist das zeigt unser unser unser Versuche so global so so zu handeln ne ja so das ist was man schon getan hatte also also.
Das war eh es ist es ist nicht, dass es jene Herz los ist, sage ich mal, es ist besser als nichts, aber das Beste wird kein großes, große Vorteile ähm bringen für Gosl.
Ja, zumal es ja ohnehin so ist. Ein ein Land handelt einfach zum großen, großen Teil mit den Ländern, die einfach geografisch in der Nähe sind. Der ganze Handelsaufkommen mit Irland ist äh größer als mit was weiß ich, USA
Brasilien und China zusammen und äh das wird natürlich hier nicht gesehen und jetzt nimmt man sich quasi siebenundzwanzig Handelspartner auf einmal äh weg
plus alle damit verbundenen Verträge der EU, die sich ja dann eben auch auf die Britstaaten und viele andere äh Bereiche der Welt eigentlich fast die ganze Welt beziehen und äh die fallen dann einfach komplett weg.
Na ja, aber es gab ja noch eine große, große Hoffnung, denn ein Trade Deal könnte ja alles retten, das ist natürlich äh die Special Relationship mit den USA und
besondere Boris Johnson großer Fan wie die ganzen Brexiteers von äh Donald Trump. Äh da würde er dann auf jeden Fall die Rettung kommen.
Scheint nicht geklappt zu haben.
Das ist eins von dieser sehr verrückten Aspekten von dem ganzen Brexit. Also ein Freihandelsabkommen in den verweimeten Staaten war auch die Abstimmung von.
Sowie von dem äh von dem Senat. Und seit zweitausendachtzehn,
hatten die Demokraten schon die Kontrolle von dem Hause Repräsentips und den von den Republikanern übernommen. Also das bedeutet seit zweitausendachtzehn.
War ein Freihandelsabkommen mit den Freien Staaten für Großbritannien schon unmöglich. Aber es gab immer noch diese Sprüche von Trump. Ja, ja, das, das ist möglich und so weiter. Also es war nie die Realität. Punkt ein.
Zweitens, wenn man schaut in die Themenfelder, was für Themenfelder wolle dem freilädchen Staat ins Ohren ein Freihandelsabkommen besonders Agrarpolitik
und Gesundheitswesen
Was für für äh Themenfelder wollen die Briten auf keinen Fall in so einen freien Umsatz kommen? Agrarpolitik und das Gesundheitswesen. Was wollen die Briten für ähm ähm so für die Finanzmärkte, also Finanzindustrien.
Was wollen die vor allen Dingen den Staaten nicht? Finanzindustrie. Also das bedeutet, wenn man schaue dann in den Details, wenn es auch seit zweitausendachtzehn wäre so ein feierndes Abkommen,
Unmöglich. Also was bedeutet das war nur eine Idee in den Köpfen von den Brexit Heals in den letzten zwei Jahren.
Jetzt ist dann jetzt kommt dann beiden in beiden Sachen okay, dann wir wollen kein feiern uns abkommen. Also es ist fertig gesehen. Keine große Änderung,
Aber es ist eine Änderung in wie man das in Großbritannien debattiert. Auch so was bedeutet das, man kann nicht weiterhin träumen
irgendwie, also die dieses Traumformeln. Es war in den letzten zwei Wochen zwei Jahre nur ein Traum,
auch dieses Traum gibt es ja nicht mehr. Was haben die Buden, die Britische Brexit-Befürworter dann gesagt.
Ja so ein feierndes Abkommen mit den USA war für uns nie sehr wichtig.
Ja? Also hier Moment mal so, wofür ist dann dieses Brexit? Also die haben dann in zwanzig sechs ihnen gesagt, ja, na klar, also ein Deal mit Brüssel ist, wobei die Easy Steel in History, ja? Nee, ja, so ist es nicht. Das haben wir jetzt erfahren.
Die haben dann in zwanzig, achtzehn, zwanzig neunzehn gesagt. Ja, wir wollen einen Deal mit den Vereinigten starten. Jetzt sagen die, nur es war für uns dann nicht nie mehr so wichtig. Also,
was ist
dann überhaupt den Sinn von wirtschaftlichen Sinn von dieses Brexit. Also ja, ein White Freihandelsabkommen mit Japan, was keine Vorteile bringt
Äh also es ist,
wirtschaftlich gesehen, es ist es ist echt verrückt, was was die gerade dann voranbringen. Also, wir hauen jetzt ein neues Ton aus Washington
aber die praktischen Auswirkungen, es g
ja keine praktischen Auswirkungen, weil es war immer noch immer nur ein Traum in den letzten paar Jahren, obwohl die Brexiteers das gar nicht akzeptiert haben.
Ja.
Dazu kommt natürlich also dieser Widerstand ist ja auch gar nicht mal nur ein Rein auf wirtschaftlichen Argumenten basieren da, sondern gerade äh der Kongress hat ja schon relativ klar gesagt, dass alles, was halt das Karfreitagsabkommen
beschädigt für sie sowieso nicht hinkommt und mit Joe Beiden als Präsident kriegt das jetzt sozusagen nochmal ein ganz neuen Spin, denn er ist ja auch aus irischer Abstimmstammung.
Hat das auch selber immer wieder betont und überhaupt muss man sehen in den USA
ist sind die irischen Auswanderer, die spielen da einfach eine große Rolle, ja? Das ist nicht
einzige Rolle, die er gespielt wurde, aber das ist sozusagen ein ein äh es ist sehr viele Leute aus Irland in die USA, migriert über die Jahrhunderte. Äh gerade auch wegen dieser Hungerszeit äh aus anderen Gründen und äh deswegen ist das sozusagen jetzt nicht
so 'n Land, was
Was die nicht so interessiert, wie, was weiß ich, irgend so ein anderes Drittweltland, was sie wo sie gar nicht wissen, wo das auf der Karte ist, sondern das ist schon so ein ein wichtiger Fleck
und ähm dementsprechend kann man davon ausgehen, dass hier einfach überhaupt nichts möglich ist. Mal ganz davon abgesehen, dass es halt auch selbst wenn irgendwas möglich wäre. Ukay auch nicht rettet.
Genau, aber wenn man hört, was die, die Brexiteers zu dem zu diesem Thema Themenfeldern sagen, John Redwood oder ihn, dann ging's mit, also die, die Hardline ist, Jerry Biking, Butt Outiwate, also.
Lieber sich raushalten, sagen die.
Was ist das dann mit dem Special Vollation? Ich habe mir den vor einigen Staaten, also wenn die Interessen von den Vereinigten Staaten sich ändern, Großmittel ist erlockt, die wir wollen, dann keinen guten Special Relationship mit den Fragen gestanden. So.
Irgendwie, also für eine ein nicht alle konservativen Abgeordneten, aber für ein.
Substanziellen Teil der konservativen, das einzige.
Wichtige Ziel ist, Brexit muss man machen können. Also man weiß ja nicht mehr, warum,
wofür? Man weiß ja nicht nicht mehr, wem könnte davon profitieren. Es ist irgendwie, wie ist auch eine religiöse Glaube geworden? Man muss es einfach tun. Und.
Und und Autobreiten können die kann die die Conservativen von von dieses Kurs zur Zeit nicht abschrecken,
nichts funktioniert. Also die sind so komplett realitätsfern. Und das ist was die gemeinsam mit mit Donald Trump dann haben, diese diese dass die so Fan von der Realität sind.
Natürlich eher so ein so ein Vergleich, der sich ja die ganze Zeit aufgedrängt hat, so dieser Trump Pizza, dieses
ich lüge jetzt einfach mal so lange äh bis es bis es wirklich nicht mehr geht und man merkt halt in der Öffentlichkeit, man kommt halt doch nochmal deutlich weiter als äh gedacht und dann macht man's halt auch einfach immer weiter. Jetzt würde ich nicht sagen, dass
Boris Johnson so auf dem Level von äh Trump spielt so, das äh ist ohnehin glaube ich ein Level, was schwierig zu erreichen ist.
Alle dem ist er natürlich so im internationalen Vergleich dann schon relativ bald der nächste auf der Liste. Und hat denn jetzt diese Wahl.
Und der Ausgang dieser Wahl hier in irgendeiner Form so einen psychologischen Effekt, dass das sozusagen irgendwie so eine.
Care von.
Von Trumpison und dass es dann auch so eine Abkehr von Johnsonison ist oder ist es doch zu früh zu sagen.
Es ist schwierig zu sein, also das war zumindest die Hoffnung in Großbritannien, ja Johnson.
Kann irgendwas aus dieser Erfahrung dann lernen, er hat ja versucht.
Offen zu beiden zu sein, also also das Bein anderen Staatschefs angerufen hatte gestern, also Johnson, Herr Macron, Merkel, Martin, in den, in den Irland und und und.
Angerufen, so damit und Johnson sich so so wohl fühlt. Also ähm,
Johnson sprach in den letzten paar Tagen viel so zu dem Thema Cop siebenundzwanzig. Das findet in Großbritannien statt. Der hofft auf eine gute Zusammenarbeit mit mit,
beiden in den in Sachen so Klimawandelbekämpfung. Aber was.
Was sind die praktischen Auswirkungen? Wir haben ja keine praktischen Auswirkungen gesehen, also kommen wir so zu dieser Abstimmung in dem im Oberhaus am neunten November, zu dem Internet Marke, also dieses Internal Marketer Stoß klar gegen den,
den Karfreitag der Abkommen und.
Hat mehrmals betont während im Wahlkampf im September und und mal wieder diese Woche.
Also das ist für mich mein US-Präsident sehr wichtig, das müssen wir verteidigen
Was hat dann dann Johnson dann getan? Die Getarnung gesagt. Nein, wir kämpfen gegen diese Position der House of Lords
Ja, also wir wollen dieses Gesetz, so wie er jetzt ist,
verteidigen können und und und wir verteidigen unsere Position gegenüber den House of Londs. So,
eine wirkliche Änderung wäre dann so akzeptieren, dass dieses Gesetz so sehr problematisch ist für alle, ja, für beiden, für die, für Irland, für die EU und sagen, okay,
Wir ändern unsere Position. Das hat Johnson definitiv nicht gemacht. Daher genau den Gegenteil gemacht. Also
ich, ich bin, ich, ich bin bereit, dass ich sehe, es es könnte eine Änderung ja geben.
Aber dieses Änderung haben wir in den letzten Tagen bis jetzt aus meiner Sicht zumindest in Sachen Brexit haben wir keine Änderungen gesehen.
Ist denn ein Eindruck von Boris Johnson, dass er eigentlich sich nur so von Tag zu Tag rettet? Oder gibt es hier irgendeine langfristige Strategie, die er verfolgt wird?
Es gibt ja keine langfristige Strategie und und aus meiner Sicht. Ich höre immer.
Deal ist immer was Boris Johnson wollte. Keine Ahnung. Äh ich ich bin ja nicht sicher, was was Boris Johnson je wollte. Also das ist was, so sehr schwierig ist mit mit Boris Johnson.
Erhard keine klare Ideologie. Man weiß ja nie, was er wirklich will
Also ich will wichtig werden und er will an der Markt bleiben, aber irgendwie erschwankt selbst. Es ist nicht, dass er ein klares Ziel irgendwie hat,
ja? Also es gab ein.
Ähm äh so ein ein Orpad in Megadien von Raffael Bar, also der Cellty den zu den besten Kommentatoren in den britischen Medien. Er sagte.
Johnson, das whatever the last personal toked to him salt. So war's der letzte Person, der etwas zu ihm gesagt hatte, ihm gesagt hatte, dass es was er dann entscheidet. Also das bedeutet.
Er ist so verdammt unfähig. Also er kann.
Er kann nichts verteidigen, weil er weiß ja nicht, was er selbst politisch erreichen will. Also das bedeutet, ist er für Deal oder für No Deal jetzt? Wir wissen nicht, wir können nicht wissen. So das bedeutet, er ist für was er.
Es erhöht erhöht die Chancen, dass er an der Macht bleibt. Ja und dann ist es dann sehr schwierig, dann grobes Wissen was ist das,
so kann sein, dass No Deal einfach also kommunizieren ist, ist der vielleicht Fenode,
weil ein Deal besser für die Wirtschaft ist, das hilft ihm vielleicht auf der anderen Seite. Also wir wissen es wirklich nicht. Und er ist.
So bereit, am, einen Tag ein Ding zu sagen und am Tag danach genau den Gegenteil, dass wir wissen nicht, was er wirklich glaubt. Ähm
hat vor ein paar Tagen gesagt, ja, wir wollen nun bedingt
an die müssen ist und können wir, ja, morgen machen mit unseren Freunden in der EU, aber vor ein paar Wochen hat er genau den Gegenteil gesagt, also das ist was, dieses ganze Ding so so schwierig macht
Und das ist, was ich an empfehle von den Berichte oder die die Diskussion über Boris Johnson.
So Hasse in Großbritannien. Ja, aus aus Londoner Bürgermeister, der war pragmatisch und liberal.
Das bedeutet, der ist pragmatisch in Liberale, das stimmt ja nicht. Also als Außenminister war er nicht pragmatisch und liberal, ja? Der will genau den Gegenteil, so wie auch während der Brexit Referendum. Also das ist was.
Was für ihn gar nicht mit ihm so kapiert haben. Und irgendwie auch wenn wir gucken.
Grob alle.
Alle Regierungen Großbritanniens, auch die Regierung, die irgendwie böse waren, mit mit dem Rückblick, die Regierung von Margaret Fadschan, Großbritannien zum Beispiel.
Man hatte so grob noch den Eindruck, dass die hatten irgendein so.
Irgendwann gemeinsames Interesse an so eine Interesse in dem Wohlstand des Landes war irgendwie hart bewegt für diese andere Regierung irgendwie wichtig.
Aber das zählt irgendwie nicht für Boris Johnson. Ja, also dass die wirtschaftlich klugste Entscheidung zu treffen.
Scheint, dass es für ihn keine Rolle spielt. Und das ist was, was wie man ihn zu höpertiert, was tut dann Boris Johnson? Das ist was alles so, so, so, so schwierig, so interpretieren macht.
Die normalen Regeln gelten für ihn irgendwie nicht.
Und warum ist das so?
Also man muss zurück.
In seinem Hintergrund greifen, denke ich. Ähm es gibt ja, es es gibt ja ein ein neues, so ein Buch über ihn.
Und in und die Interpretation in dieses äh in dieses neue Buch ist ähm das er hatte so eine.
Unfreudige Kindheit, dass er immer.
Beliebt und machtvoll sein wollte. Was er selbst in den ähm.
In seine Kindheit nie hatte und er hatte so.
Irgendwie gelernt, wenn er so zu sein Vater und die die sehr schwierige Beziehung zwischen seinen seinem Vater und seine Mutter beobachtet hatte,
Regeln, gelten irgendwie nicht. Das ist normal, normal ist ein Ding zu sagen und vor dem Gegenteil zu machen.
Ähm es scheint für mir für mich also irgendwie eine.
Eine kluge Art und Weise Boris Johnson zu interpretieren zu sein.
Aber dann ist gibt's natürlich die Frage, wie kann es dann sein, dass so jemand an der Macht kommt, aber die gleiche Frage könnte man auch dann für Trump dann.
Ähm äh dann stellen. Es ist irgendwie, dass die die Unterstützer von Boris Johnson. Boris Johnson kann für diese Menschen sein.
Was liebt, was alle Leute in ihm sehen wollen, kann irgendwie halbwegs.
Richtig sein. Ja, der ist pragmatisch, der ist liberal für einen Tory, der erreicht Wähler, die sonst die Tories nie wählen werden. Stimmt ja halbwegs.
Der ist ein Populist, der lügt.
Der ist in Sachen ähm ähm Einwanderung so sehr otoritär, der ist sogar rassistisch. Stimmt auch.
Man man hat genug Beweise dafür, ja? Also was bedeutet das? Er kann mit dieser.
Unklarheit oder dass er Dingen gesagt hat und genau den Gegenteil kann er dann vielleicht genug für die Mehrheit der Touris dann anbieten.
Aber wenn man sieht oder wenn man lernt, wie er lügt und wie ich ständig erlügt und und dass er äh gar nicht so liefern kann, ja.
Dann hat Großbritannien Problem, aber aber das ist auch ja eine sehr schwierige. So, wenn man schaut in den Meinungsumfragen, also.
Labour haben jetzt kleine Vorsprunge vor den Konservativen, in den Meinungssuppenfragen, aber die Konservativen sind noch vierzig Prozent, ja?
Eins von den höchsten Anzahl an Kovito, große wirtschaftlichen Problemen wegen Brexit, eine eine so eine schlechte Situation in die sie so nach Kowit ähm äh Periode,
Die Regierung funktioniert ja nicht, aber die sind noch auf vierzig Prozent in den Meinungsumfragen. Also irgendwas funktioniert nicht, denn die britische politische System, dass das all das gleichzeitig stimmen kann.
Hast du den Eindruck, dass das äh auch ein Problem der Medienstruktur ist, also dass das nach wie vor durch durch die durch die medialen Transport dieser Politik getragen ist.
Ja klar, also ein bisschen diese in Sachen Cowild oder was für eine Brexit.
Wäre möglich, ja? Also was, was sehr sehr angeboten ist, ist so anders, als was in den zwanzig sechs, in den, in den Referendum angeboten war damals, ja? Gibt's eine ernsthafte Auseinandersetzung von von,
Angebot und was Großbritannien jetzt kriegt, nein, natürlich nicht. Überhaupt nicht. Also man man kriege sogar den Eindruck, dass einer ernsthafte Auseinandersetzung von was kann Politik für ein Land tun? Was bedeuten.
Ernsthaft so angenommenen Entscheidungen. Was ist Good Polocymaking? Äh.
Erscheinen erscheinen die die Brücken komplett durch zu sein zur Zeit.
Lass uns nochmal auf,
Die Auswirkungen von all dem in äh in Schottland und Neuirland schauen, weil das ist ja sozusagen auch immer so ein bisschen dieses Damoklesschwert, was noch in der,
Luft hängen, dass Schottland natürlich seine Sezessionsanstrengungen weiter vorantreibt. Ich glaube, im nächsten Frühjahr sind die nächsten Gen
Elections äh genau Mai ähm in in Schottland und ich glaube, jeder kann davon ausgehen, dass oder alle gehen davon aus
Nikolas Dergyan mit ihrem doch relativ klaren Kurs und ähm
ja klar dir sehr klar Position äh bezieht mit ihrer SMP ähm.
In ja eine eine, also nicht nur nochmal gewinnen wird, sondern unter Umständen auch wieder die die absolute Mehrheit glaube ich äh erzielen wird, also davon.
Es ist möglich, ist nicht gesetzt, aber äh so wie sich das derzeit abseit und die Umfragen, die derzeit äh auch immer wieder so nach der äh Frage soll Schottland unabhängig werden, Fragen
die gehen ja auch mittlerweile deutlich in die fünfundfünfzig Prozent Bereich oder sowas rein.
Natürlich die diese ganze Brexit-Debatte zurzeit hilft, Nicole Stergean enorm, also was Boris.
Oder wo die Regierung tut oder nicht tut in Sachen Brexit, also die die Beziehungen sind zwischen Adam London und Cardifan London.
Sehr schlecht zur Zeit. Also das bedeutet, dass.
Versuchen überhaupt nicht einen Brexit durchzuführen, was halbwegs die.
Die Interessen Schottlands oder von Wales respektieren. Also das bedeutet das hilft dann natürlich Nicole Stergen, also was was loben tut, ist nicht den unseren Interessen und,
dieses dieses Spruch kommt dann in Schottland sehr gut an. Äh.
Es heißt Unruhe in so dieser Situation in den Lampen, also Michael Gove, also der fang tisch der Brexit-Minister, aber so der der
sogenannten Cubnal Office Minister, der hat so einen besonderen Team ins Leben gerufen, um um um Schottlands Rolle in unsere Union zu bewahren oder so hieß das. Ähm.
Ich habe ja keine keine große Hoffnung, dass so ein Unit überhaupt.
Eine Auswirkung haben kann, also das was gar nicht verstanden hat, ist, es geht nicht, wenn man sagt, ja, also Schottland ist für uns wichtig, das zählt ja nicht. Man es geht um.
Sachen. Man muss etwas für Schottland leisten oder zumindest den Eindruck geben, dass ja man hört was die Bewölkerung in Schottland sagt und.
Das bedeutet, dass dass die diese Ideen, das ist grob, dass London haben noch die, die sie.
Den Eindruck, dass was in England funktioniert hat, ja? Wir haben den Spruch aus dem Fußball Well toke good game, ja so wir werden alles Gute reden.
Aber die Tatsachen stimmen ja nicht oder oder finden nicht da.
Sowas funktioniert in die schottische Debatte nicht. Ja, weil die haben dann in Schottland eine sehr starke Gegnerin mittelstergen,
Also ich ich vermute, dass es wird ein ähm äh ein ein Riesengewinn sein für die schottischen Nationalisten. Die werden versuchen ein zweites Referendum zu organisieren.
Aber es gibt Jan, die diese Diskussion können die das überhaupt da machen. Juristisch gesehen, ohne die Zustimmung Londons und zur Zeit.
Es sieht so aus, dass Boris Johnson und die Konservativen sagen, nein, das erlauben wir nicht. Und, und.
Weitere Meinungen zu diesen Themen Feld haben wir zur Zeit.
Leider nicht. Also alles steuert auf ein eine große Streit ab Mai nächstes Jahr, ja? Ähm.
Ist es sehr interessant. Ähm außer anderen Gründen ähm.
Ich muss sagen, ich ich halte das für etwas sehr gutes, dass es, es gab kein.
Keinen, so sage ich, Terrorismusproblemen oder oder Wiederbeginn von The Troubles in in Nordirland, in den in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren. Also alles blieb.
Entsprechend ruhig.
Die Beziehungen zwischen Nordirland und Irland waren dann noch in Ordnung, also Warenverkehr gab es ja, gab es ja noch.
Es gab ja interessante Weise diese Woche ein gemeinsames Brief an Bar und Year, also der Chefunterverhandler in in auf der EU-Seite,
von Alien Foster, also sie ist die Chefin von demokratisch Demokratie Party, also die die irischen.
Also die Protestanten im im nordirischen ähm äh Sambly.
Im letzten Parlament auch noch die Koalition gebildet hat mit äh den Tories unter Teresa May.
Team. Nun jetzt seit seit Johnson Ding und Hausfrau gewonnen hatte, nicht mehr ein Teil der Koalition willen. Und Michello Nela, so die ist die die Chefin in Nordirland von den Nationässen, von Shin Faine.
Und die Beine haben einen Brief, an an ähm äh an Bonjergeschi.
Wir haben ja Angst, dass die Lieferketten für unsere Supermärkte in Nordirland auseinanderbrechen.
Ab dem ersten Januar. Wir brauchen faktisch eure Hilfebrüssel.
Also was bedeutet das die Supermärkte, also sage ich britische Supermärkte, wie Saint Sprees, die haben ja Läden in Nordirland, aber nicht in Irland. Also was bedeutet das, die Notirischen Supermärkten werden aus.
Britwarenhäuser, so so oder oder so Wehrhaus ist, ja, in in England oder in Schottland beliefert.
Oder Wales, ne?
Aber die die meisten sind um, um Manchester, also die die diese Lagerhäuser. Ähm.
Großbritannien hat natürlich dann die Vorbereitungen.
Wie Stimmgräf. Also das bedeutet, dass wenn man muss dann auch die, weil wie du am Beginn von dem Podcast gesagt hast, dass das Nordirland bleibe, so grob nimm.
Wirtschaftsraum von die EU.
Das bedeutet, man muss die in den Hafen von Bellfast ankommen, aus England.
Nicht kontrollieren, zumindest ein System haben, um zu wissen, was gibt's in dieses Container oder in diesem LKW.
Und diese Systeme und diese Kontrollstelle hat Großbritannien einfach nicht gebaut. Ja, also die sind ja nicht fertig. Also das bedeutet, dass Supermärkte und dann die diese nur nierische Politiker, die haben mir dann Angst, so Moment mal, also kann es sein, dass,
unser Supermärkte kriegen die Waren danach. Nee, stammt im ersten Januar. Aber dann London ist dafür schon der ist nicht Brüssel.
Und ich finde das dann sehr interessant, dass die haben dann diese offene Briefe an Barmier geschickt, also das interpretiere ich dann als Moment mal, aber so Busse, wir brauchen Hilfe, weil wir kriegen diese Hilfe aus London nicht,
Ähm also ähm das ist ja sehr interessant, aber wir wissen natürlich, dass diese Vorbereitungen sind, die die Großbritannien ist nicht vorbereitet
Ja, weil die Computersysteme funktionieren nicht, die Kontrollstellen existieren ja nicht. Und natürlich man habe ja Angst, aber sorry, Alinforste von den DOP. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen zu spät
wir wissen schon seit seit Ende Juni, dass diese Situation stattfinden wird. Und wenn Notila nicht vorbereitet ist und wenn Großbritannien nicht vorbereitet,
Also das ist die Show von Nordirland und von Großbritannien, das ist nicht die EU ist nicht daran schon. Ähm also das bedeutet, dass grob.
Ich bin ja sicher, dass man praktische Lösungen finden kann
aber grob wirtschaftlich, groß Nordirland steuert klar auf einen Kurs für tiefere wirtschaftliche Integration mit den Rest von Irland und nicht eine tiefere Integration, mit dem Rest von Großbritannien, aber das ist
die logische Schlussfolgerung von dem Brexit-Abkommen, was Boris Johnson selbst abgeschlossen hatte. Ähm
Ja, also ähm es ist nicht ohne Probleme, ne, aber die Probleme sind hauptsächlich zurzeit,
praktische Problemen. Äh die sind nicht unbedingt Sicherheitsproblemen oder äh oder so, sage ich fehlende Friedensprobleme.
Aber dazu könnte es ja relativ schnell kommen. Wenn man jetzt mal davon einfach mal davon ausgehen
Boris Johnson auch die nächsten Wochen sich durchwurschtelt und zu keiner klaren Entscheidung fällig ist. Es kommt zu keinem Deal,
Ja, also wir haben jetzt wirklich mal diese No Deal Situation, nichts ist klar geregelt
damit sind dann sozusagen alle Grenzen erstmal zu und der Handel zwischen Großbritannien und EU,
einerseits bestenfalls den WHO-Riegeln entsprechen, die hohe Tarife vorsehen, wo was eine ganze Menge Handel sowieso erstmal komplett ausschließen würde. Und
Handel, der dann trotzdem noch irgendwie übrig bliebe, würde wahrscheinlich ähm kaum stattfinden können, weil es einfach rein logistisch nicht funktioniert, weil es keine Software gibt, um das abzuhandeln, man muss halt für jeden.
Häfen sind blockiert, ja ja.
Es würde auch die komplette, also es ist halt so dieses alte No Deal Szenario, was wir im Prinzip vor zwei Jahren auch schon mal äh so herbeigesponnen haben, wo man sich halt immer dachte, na ja, das ist ja immer so katastrophal. Dazu kann's ja gar nicht kommen und man dachte halt auch immer, das Parlament wäre in der Lage,
das dann auch noch zu verhindern, wie das gelaufen ist, das haben wir ja hier nun in den letzten Jahren auch ausführlich besprochen,
Aber jetzt droht das ja im Prinzip. Und dann ist es natürlich so, klar, man kann sich ja dann äh lustig machen, so höh, höh, kein, kein französischer Käse mehr im Supermarkt. Das ist es ja eigentlich nicht
sondern das bedeutet halt unter Umständen auch überhaupt ein Problem mit der Nahrungsmittelversorgung, ein Problem mit der Belieferung der Wirtschaft, einfach auch in ganz, ganz.
Mit genau Medikamente ist auch so ein klassisches Beispiel, aber es fehlt im Prinzip auch viel Kleinkram, der letzten Endes auch Unternehmen am Laufen hält. Wir haben das ja irgendwie hier mit dem Klopapier auch schon mal so gehabt. Es braucht nur irgend so eine bestimmte Produktgruppe
wegzubrechen und sofort geht eine unglaubliche Nervosität los. Das dann noch gekoppelt mit Hamsterkäufen und äh entsprechend äh steigenden Preisen. Dann werden die Leute halt noch verrückter
Und äh dann bist du halt relativ schnell äh so im Bereich der brennenden Mülltonnen und das Ganze dann halt mal weiter gedacht so mit äh äh Nordirland. Da wird's natürlich dann besonders schwierig, weil die einfach so ein hohes Erregungspotential haben.
Muss dann halt immer noch sagen, also dann hängt's ja auch so ein bisschen davon ab, weil äh eigentlich ist ja dann
alles ungeregelt, weil auf der einen Seite sollte der Wirtschaftsverkehr nur zwischen Nordirland und Irland nochmal weiter funktionieren können
könnte aber dann irgendwie auf einmal doch nicht und sie würden gegen dieses Karfreitagsabkommen verstoßen, also wir haben potentiell, sage ich mal, ein echtes Sicherheitsproblem, unmittelbar vor der Tür und das Ganze während einer Pandemie.
Ja, aber innorieren zumindest gibt's einen Weg, das Hauptwegsregeln zu können, pragmatisch gesehen, ja? Wenn.
Wenn Lohn sowas akzeptieren könnte. Es wäre dann Noteland aus Irland beliefern zu können.
Ja, also.
Hängt davon ab, wie pragmatisch, Londen in so eine Situation wäre, ja. Die das bedeutet, ich gebe Lösungen für notierische Lieferketten. Ja, all das über Dublin zu überliefern zu können.
Die praktischen Probleme für die Ketten in Großbritannien sind.
Deutlich größer und auch wenn man schaut, was die britischen Bauer produzieren im Vergleich zu
was die Briten essen. Ja, so das bedeutet Großbritannien Exportieren auch eine Menge Lebensmittel und inportiert ja enorm viel. Ähm ach so ja, also das könnte,
die Frage für mich wäre, wann, wann beginne dann so die die Panik und.
Wir haben verdammt wenig Zeit, ja? Also.
Go, noch einmal zu erläutern. Also die beiden Seiten brauchen einen Deal bis den zwanzigsten November. Muss man sagen, Ende der Woche, nächste Woche.
Wenn kein Deal steht, bis Ende der Woche nächste Woche. Man muss mal da mal sagen, es kann ja
und sage ich normale Lummenständen, kein Deal ja geben bis Ende des Jahres. Und beiden Seiten müssen sich ja dann auf No Deal dann vorbereiten können. Also das ist ja erschreckend
Ich muss ja mal wieder diese Woche ein ernsthaftes Anruf haben mit meinem Vater, der in noch in Großbritannien lebt und ein besondere Medikamente für hohes Bluetooth braucht.
Ich muss eins doch mit ihm sprechen, um zu sagen, hey Dart, ich muss dich dann mal fragen, hast du genug Medikamente für die nächsten sechs Monate? Weil wir können mietsicher sein, dass du die noch kriechst.
Was ist das? Ja? Und mitten in einem Korone Pandini. Ja? Aber das sind die Diskussionen, die man in den nächsten Monaten haben muss.
Das sieht doch alles total super aus, würde ich sagen. Also.
Ja, grob. Ah nur noch eine andere, ein anderes Punkt, ja? Ist.
Sagen wir mal, dass Boris Johnson schließt ein Deal mit Brüssel ab, ja? In den nächsten zehn Tagen. Kommt als große Siege zurück.
Ich habe einen Deal in der Hand, ja? So, wie wie er das getan hatte in den November letztes Jahr.
Diesmal gibt's keine formelle parlamentarische Abstimmung, weil das Britsche und Haushalt schon abgestimmt, dass die brauchen ja keine formelle Abstimmung,
um einen zugfündigen Brexit Deal abzustimmen. Es gibt eine intice so eine eine Resolution, aber das Britsche und Haus kann das Ding nie stoppen.
Wenn er einen Deal angeschossen hat.
Aber was tun dann die Tories? Ja, also es hält schon Ruhe auf die konservative Bänke gegen Boris Johnson wegen Korona, ja.
Was was können die Konservativen dann tun, wenn die Sauer auf so einem Deal sind? Und es gibt ja,
Es gibt ja genug, die sau auf ihn mal im Deal sind, ja? Es ist komplett außer Frage, dass die versuchen ein No-Competence ähm Votum einzuleiten gegen Boris Trumpson als Parteichef.
Das wäre ja möglich, wenn die Sau genug sind. Ja, so das bedeutet, dass,
Die konservative Hinterbänkler, auch wenn er einen Deal mit Brüssel findet, dass die versuchen ihm zu stürzen,
Es ist schwierig, ja? Die brauchen fünfundfünfzig Abgeordnete, die bereit sind zu sagen, ich hab ja kein Vertrauen in Boris Johnson, aber ich bin nicht hundert Prozent sicher, dass die das nicht versuchen,
Also was bedeutet das? Auch wenn er rettet etwas mit einem Deal, ja? Hat er dann enorme Schwierigkeiten, parteiintern.
SOS ist die die Wochen bis Ende November, also sind vollkommen erschreckend, aber politisch in Großbritannien.
Genau, das Richtige, was man sich wünscht für für Weihnachten.
Für Weihnachten wäre ein.
Oh man.
Ja John. Ich glaube jetzt haben wir erstmal wieder die den Stand der Dinge ganz gut eingefangen. Klingt nicht besonders beruhigend, aber das war die ganze Geschichte ja sowieso. Bisher noch nicht.
Stimmt.
Andererseits habe ich so ein bisschen den Eindruck.
Dass wir uns jetzt auch so einen Moment der Klarheit irgendwie äh mehr nähern, als wir das bisher getan haben. Ob das alles so erfreulich sein wird, weiß,
aber es muss jetzt langsam mal was auf den Tisch. Äh es gibt jetzt gar nicht mehr so viele Optionen. Ähm, irgendwas noch groß rauszuzögern. Man weiß nur noch nicht, welche der beiden schlechten Wege eingeschlagen wird.
Und was ist so deine Einschätzung, wann die äh britische Bevölkerung dann mal aufwacht und und sagt so, ey, was haben wir da eigentlich getan.
Die letzte Woche vom November oder oder Anfang Dezember.
Meinst du, dass es dann schon einsetzt, ja?
Dann richtig anfangen wird.
Mhm. Okay, ich bin gespannt. Ja, super, weiß nicht, hast du noch irgendwas äh hinten.
Nee, also das sind die, das ist jetzt die Situation, also Brexit wird in den Starksaalen mal wieder sein in den nächsten, den nächsten Wochen. Es gibt es gibt keinen Weg, dass das vermeiden weiter.
Gut. Na dann äh ahne ich schon, dass wir uns ähm ein bisschen früher wieder treffen werden als erst in äh.
Kann sein kann sein.
Weil jetzt wird's halt mal wieder spannend. Okay, ich sage äh vielen Dank, John.
Herzlichen Dank, ja.
Und äh vielen Dank an alle hier wieder beim Zuhören von UKW, unsere kleine Welt äh folgt uns auf ME Unterstrich UKW und ja bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschau.